it's true the next call of duty is cold
war
and it's going back to the black ops
timeline but with some new twists
here's everything we know about the
campaign so far
cold war is a direct sequel to black ops
1
which is why you're going to see a lot
of footage from that game in this video
it's set between one and two and
according to treyarch the story is all
about government conspiracy and
political paranoia
most of the game takes place in the 80s
with the us
under the leadership of president ronald
reagan who's an actual character in the
story
it's going to take us all over the world
from asia to europe to north and latin
america
we saw three locations during our
presentation including a mid-game
mission in ukraine
spetsnaz forces were training to invade
the us the following mission looked a
lot like hitman
giving you lots of player choice as you
infiltrated the lebanka building in
moscow
in the first half of the mission you
could steal items and poison
bribe or blackmail people in the
building the second part of the mission
turned into the guns blazing escape
you'd expect from call of duty
lastly we saw a flashback mission set in
laos during the vietnam war
that mission is something of a time loop
where you relive the same memory over
and over again
making different choices and taking
alternate mission paths each time
the goal of the memory was to remember
perseus cold war's main villain
perseus is based on a real real-life
cold war spy who may or may not have
existed
whoever they are they've stolen a lot of
classified information in this game
dating all the way back to the manhattan
project including a possible stolen nuke
and they must be stopped you'll see some
familiar black ops faces in the campaign
too
our presentation included mason woods
and hudson
you'll be playing as a custom character
yourself demonstrating how cold war
wants to give you
more choices in fact the campaign
missions are more open-ended
with side missions and dialogue options
at certain points
there are also some full completely
optional side missions
all of these will come together to
affect the game with multiple endings
so when can you actually get your hands
on the next call of duty
black ops cold war is launching on
november 13th
it's coming to ps5 this holiday season
making use of the next gen console's
haptic feedback
plus 4k and hdr support we're still
waiting on a multiplayer reveal
too although based on all the current
teasers it'll likely tie into warzone
stay tuned to gamespot for when all that
good stuff gets announced
[Music]
you